we're talking about reconciliation silly
ation and faith today there are two
examples one is from South Africa and
the Truth and Reconciliation Commission
where the issue was not specifically
religious but where the religious people
that have been involved in the process
of reconciliation and and Desmond Tutu
actually headed up the Commission and
and obviously that was very important in
coloring if you like the sentiment with
which the Commission went about its
business that was really the importance
of religion in that and faith in that
context then the second is specifically
from Nigeria where there has been
violence between Christian and Muslim
it's basically a country whose
population is pretty much 5050 Christian
and Muslim and there it is about how two
people who were both engaged in
religious violence came to
reconciliation with each other and
between between their face and it's
those are worth just studying and
looking at and you can do that but
please leave without me taking you
through each slide now I'd like to build
on what Varys love has just been talking
about first proposition is that religion
is a major factor in most of the complex
in the world today now I know you're
going to do complex next week but just
to give you an appetizer that's not the
wrong thing to say in the context
conflict for for next week and religion
there's no point in disputing this
religion is a major part of most of the
conflicts that are going on in the world
today now it can be intra religion
Protestant Catholics and easier but it
is also I think right to say that
sometimes we describe an internal
conflict which may be for example let's
say in Afghanistan today when you
analyze it yes it is internal between
different groups but it also has an
external dimension
importance and in many ways the internal
dispute within the religion is a symbol
of an external issue about that
religions interaction with with the
Western world and with other face if you
think of Yemen today for example where
you've got a government you've got an
al-qaida dimension you've got an
iranian-backed dimension you could
describe that as an internal dispute but
actually it's just got massive external
consequences and in many ways the
internal dispute is a surrogate for for
that external question the simple point
of course to make is that there are
political factors in all these disputes
that may exhibit or express themselves
in religious terms but nonetheless there
are political factors and you can think
of the Mindanao dispute in the
Philippines you can think of what is
happening in Thailand today so my
proposition to you is not that religion
is the factor in these conflicts but it
is a significant dimension of them and
what is more it's usually but not always
usually a fight that has a or a conflict
that has a an air to it that is about
people being worried that their I their
identity is under threat their way of
life is under threat from the other
often from modernity or globalization
and they are trying to prevent it so if
you look at the Middle East as a whole
today in many ways the clash that's
going on there expressed in different
forms is a clash between those who
believes that the Middle East should
modernize and engage with the world and
the process of globalization and those
who believe that that is actually a
threat their way of life that it's
undermining their essential cultural and
religious identity and if you go
straight to the israel-palestine
question and some settlers
on the west bank our people are there
for an economic reason but others are
there for a very specifically religious
reason and their belief is that there is
no such thing as an occupation but
they're actually they have a historic
right and to settle in in this in this
country on the west bank and that is
very much linked to their religious view
of Judaism indeed some of those people
will actually oppose the concept of the
State of Israel because they believe
that that is inconsistent in fact with
their essential religious belief if you
look at the position of Christians on
the palace in the Palestinian territory
there has been a very steady and clear
diminution in the numbers of Christians
able to stay in places like Bethlehem
it's quite a serious issue actually but
it's it's planar that's there and that
is for many reasons to do with the
overall conflict but also in part to do
with the feeling that they are under
pressure because of their religious
belief and if you take the situation in
Jerusalem which is a place of holy
worship for for Jews for Christians and
the Muslims yes of course there are many
political factors that go to make up
this dispute but it would be absurd I
would suggest to eliminate the religious
dimension from from the issue I would
say even in Northern Ireland where in a
way you could say that and most
obviously it is about the United Kingdom
versus united Ireland you could say it's
about land you could say it's about
class actually to a certain degree
certainly economic opportunity
nonetheless the fact is it divided on
Catholic Protestant lines and there were
many indirect cultural consequences of
that that were very important so my
first proposition is is is this and I
think it is pretty clear which is that
religion and religious faith is a major
dimension
of most conflicts in the world today not
the only but a major dimension the
second proposition is which may seem
obvious when you've stated the first
proposition but I think doesn't often
appear obvious to people is that
therefore faith is relevant to
reconciliation in other words if if it
is a major of dimension in the conflict
let me put it it is minimal
reconciliation may not happen even if it
has the support of the faith community
but I would suggest it is highly
unlikely to happen in circumstances
where reconciliation does not have the
support of the faith community and if we
take the situation in Northern Ireland
there would have been no peace in
Northern Ireland if the faith community
is indeed i think scott i will be and is
doing smiler thinking in their their
works indicate the faith community
hadn't got on side with it in
significant degree not all parts of it
but into in a significant degree if the
faith community be irreconcilable to be
would have been pretty much I don't
think you could have contemplated the
prospect of a peace process that
succeeded so that is the second
proposition which raises the third which
is that if religion is a major factor in
most conflicts and if faith in the
support of the faith community is a
significant part of the process of
reconciliation what are the conditions
for faith to be an advantage or support
to reconciliation what are the
circumstances in which it is likely that
religious faith is supporting that
process of reconciliation or perhaps
another way putting what are the
characteristics that we would look for
in the faith community when that process
of reconciliation is underway and i
would suggest there are four really
number one em or a bigger boat since
I've got three mobile got a still
lawyers training their key faith groups
must not see reconciliation as contrary
to their faith now let me seem an odd
thing to say but let me explain what I
mean there a faith group may say this is
not a just solution and therefore we're
not in favor of it so the absence of
justice it may be a reason why a key
faith group says well we don't support
this process of reconciliation or for
example there may be a dispute about the
holy places associated with that faith
in other words there may be a
geographical that mirror stuff and I
were discussing this morning is that
that sometimes there is a geographical
very specific geographical data
dimension to faith which means that a
process of reconciliation that may be
about compromise becomes impossible
because people say we cannot compromise
on this so for example if there were to
be not there would be but if for the
sake of the hypothesis there were to be
an agreement that say excluded Islam
from Jerusalem that would not be
supported by the world of Islam by by
Muslims it wouldn't matter what other
aspects of it but that would be
considered as something that was being
considerate as unjust but they would
also consider this contrary to their
religion and therefore this proposition
that is that for the context for faith
to play a positive role in
reconciliation the key faith groups must
not see reconciliation as contrary to
their faith and 3b if you like I think
forgiveness and the concept of
forgiveness
is an important precondition for faith
groups to play a positive or
advantageous role in reconciliation and
I think this question of forgiveness is
treated differently in different
religious faiths for sure but it is a
very vital part of people of faith
coming to the point at which they can
say despite what has happened we done
that nonetheless can reach out to the
person that was our enemy and is now
either not our enemy or even our friend
and what are the most difficult issues
in respect of Northern Ireland for
example but this is true in respect of
Israel Palestine is that you have to be
prepared as someone of of of faith not
necessarily someone of faith you could
be without faith and still forgive but
it's important that forgiveness when
you're dealing with a conflict in which
faith is such an important part from
forgiveness to be vital part of the
religion your religious belief because
otherwise when you're then confronted
with the person who let us say is
responsible for having killed your your
son or your daughter or your friends or
members of your community you have to be
prepared in those circumstances to put
the past behind you now that is an
incredibly difficult thing and but
forgiveness as a part of the belief of
that faith community is an important
part of faith playing a positive role
and reconciliation the third
characteristic that I think has to be
present is
that if you have an exclusive view of
your religious faith in other words mine
is the true faith you you have to carry
within that faith exclusive though it is
and this is the point that mirrors lap
was making earlier if you like and the
antidote to your own poisoners and
sometimes called in other words you may
believe that yours is the only true
faith but nonetheless your faith is able
to encompass the view that either God's
love is universal or there is a there is
a universal application of the
principles of human dignity and so even
if you believe I get salvation the
person who's not on my face doesn't get
salvation nonetheless your your view of
religion has to be sufficiently open to
some fundamental values that encompass
more than the people of your faith in
order for reconciliation to work and the
fourth and I think I'm stolen 3d
actually is faith can play a strong part
in reconciliation if of course your
faith is non-exclusive right so if you
take a spectrum where where you regard
people of other faiths right you start
with tolerance you tolerate them you may
not agree with in you and I like them
but you tolerate them the next stage
area saves acceptance did you accept
them you're more than tolerate them you
accept them but the father said to the
spectrum you can actually respect them
they are of a different faith but
nonetheless you respect that face
doesn't mean to say you you're not
diminished in support of your own paper
you take a non-exclusive view of your
faith
so you say is I think I would say you
know someone's brought up a Hindu in a
remote part of India and they live their
entire life and they do good work and
they they die they never you they're not
a Christian they've been a Hindu or
their life to me I I i would i would
have I would have issues with with the
goblet declared this is such a person as
destined for hell rather than rather
than heaven on that basis so I think
undoubtedly the easiest way that faith
plays its part in in reconciliation is
if there is that that ability to respect
those of a different face so to
summarize it for faith to be of
advantage or support for reconciliation
the conditions of characteristics are a
faith groups must not see reconciliation
as contrary to faith be there is a
concept of forgiveness that is integral
to that faith see if exclusive in the
view of religion it nonetheless has
within that concept of religion a
fundamental belief in University
universality of God's level human
dignity and D that actually where its
most advantageous will be where there is
a non exclusion the exclusive view of
your own religion the fourth point is
therefore this and it follows from the
argument and the rest of the point so if
it is the case that religion is a major
factor and if it is the case that for
the faith therefore can be a major part
of reconciliation and if it is the case
that the easiest way that faith can play
that part is if it is
has that concept of respect for others
then the fourth proposition is that
interfaith dialogue and action improve
the prospects of reconciliation and are
actually an important dimension to that
reconciliation and I think where it is a
natural part of the reconciliation
process then reconciliations more likely
to succeed and conflict is less likely
to recur one of the things that was
absolutely bizarre to me about the
Northern Ireland situation and I think I
may have said this G last time we met so
forgive me for repeating it but it's
relevant to this is is is how
Protestants could tell Catholics and
Catholics can tell Protestants and
walking down the street without actually
talking to each other ever told you
about this but no one of the most of
curious things because sometimes I used
to say to either side you'd hear a story
of a a Catholic who would go into the
Shankill Road which is the most violent
Protestant part of the time and they
would literally come out let's say they
came out of a fish and chip shop right
not talking to anybody and they kicked
the devil on the street right nobody and
I just said it but how can anybody tell
this young guy comes out you know we're
we're living in I mean okay its northern
islands in the United Kingdom in the
late 20th century on earth can somebody
tell me and that each side would say to
me know a way we can spot it immediately
and the fascinating thing is when I put
the same point to Muslim friends about
Sunni and Shiah for example Iraqis that
I asked about this again we can tell
straight away I said why do you mean you
can tell I mean it's a that's that mean
obviously when they speak you can tell
but surely before you cannot you know we
can tell
is that right yeah so they go and it's
an extraordinary it's an extraordinary
thing so it's it's an instantaneous
recognition of difference and it's
relevant the point I'm making for this
reason that because that difference has
become part and a major part of the
conflict sometimes of the conflict
itself and because that difference is
engendered a whole set of fears and
anxieties about the other person right
they are going somehow their their aim
is to take over my life the reason why
interfaith dialogue in action is so
important to reconciliation is that it
requires people to talk and through
talking they are more likely to
understand it requires people to learn
and in learning they're more likely to
fear and here's the other thing that
happens hello miroslav and I were having
an interesting debate about this this
morning it I think that and points C and
D of the last bit in other words an
exclusionary view of religion but with
certain fundamental Universal concepts
and a non exclusion review become more
likely in other words that that what
actually happens is that the exclusivity
around you through the process of
interfaith dialog phrase somewhat it
just it becomes somewhat melted or
printable at the the at the at either
side of of the religious divide and so
what is interesting to me about the
common word is the common wed the
dialogue between Christians and Muslims
but it could perfectly easily
incorporate Judaism and probably will
hopefully and soon too is that each
person who goes into this dialogue
says and says very clearly my face
remains my faith but I accept that there
are certain things that we have in
common and the interesting thing is the
things they say they have in common
which is love your God love your
neighbor as yourself which all three
Abrahamic faiths have and actually if
you study Buddhism or Hinduism very much
the same concepts as she Sikhism very
directly the fact is if you share those
things in common and they are
fundamental to your faith you are
certainly already on the road to respect
rather than acceptance or tolerance I
would suggest what is more you are more
likely to see and religious faith as
something that is developing and am
including rather than something that is
exclusionary and stepping so what is
interesting to me about this process of
reconciliation in the name of faith and
let's go back to the whole title of our
course which is faith in globalization's
of what globalization about is it's very
much a modern force that is pushing
people together and you may agree with
it you may disagree with it but when we
look at the place of faith in situations
of conflict then it's very obvious to me
that in the conditions that have to
exist in the characteristics for faith
to be positive and reconciliation the
closer you are getting away from an
exclusion review the better and the more
that you are prepared to engage in
dialogue with the other
the more likely that process of other
more inclusionary notion of religious
faith is to take root now what this
actually means in which is why it's
interesting to me in sort of
geopolitical terms is that if you look
at for example Afghanistan today for
example Israel Palestine for example
actually any of the conflicts that are
now taking place not just in the in the
Middle East but more broadly then
putting the concept of an interfaith
dialogue at the center of resolving
those disputes is actually a very very
important part of creating a different
context in which people can reconcile
and that what is a fundamental mistake
is to believe that you can separate a
political process of compromise from a
religious process of reconciliation and
the implications of policy terms in fact
are very very profound because it means
that a dimension of your policy in
dealing with this not Millie it because
it's a nice thing to think about is a
good idea to do but actually an
essential prerequisite of an effective
policy is that we engage in this process
of faith as part of reconciliation and
what that does of course is it
challenges enormously those who are
engaged within those fades to come out
and be part of this and what is more to
provide if not the theological
justification at least the theological
defense of such a process in other words
the reason why the common word is
interesting is that it is clerics that
have come together to say my religious
faith does
prevent me from having this dialogue
with you because the argument in many
parts of the world is actually you're
diminishing your religion or you're
devaluing at or in some may even be
betraying it by having this religious
dialogue but actually the clerics are
providing a theological justification as
to why that isn't so and therefore it
poses massively important questions to
policymakers but it also means that you
have to mobilize feel those engaged in
theology and those engage in the
teaching of religion to be part of the
solution rather than part of the problem
so and that's why I think this is right
at the heart of the way that faith and
globalization interact with one another
and why I certainly came to the view
that without these the debate about
faith being at the center of the debate
about policy and the geopolitical
challenges we face we were unlikely to
be able to resolve them